hello everyone and welcome to what could
be the most exciting game in the Phaedo
World Cup 2019 so far it's the second
game of their match a team or a Java
versus Maxim Buffalo Grove and thank you
for you know correcting me in the
comment section saying that it's not
steamed or it's actually tame or so
sorry about that I really had no idea
always called him Timur but I'm always
happy to learn new things so tomorrow
Java versus Maxime buffalo grove their
first game ended in a draw now our job
has the white pieces and it's well it's
a it's just a very nice game so we don't
have a photo of it here it is so let's
just enjoy that for a moment not very
centered but there you have it
still no eye contact but I guess we we
have yet to see a handshake featuring an
eye contact so that being said let's
check out the game at a trouble with the
white pieces opens with Knight to f3 the
reti opening with Knight to f6 by Maxine
c4 and c5 so symmetrical with Knight to
c3 and d5 striking in the center we have
see captures Knight captures and now III
Knight captures and c3 and D captures on
c3 offering this Queen trade and even
though you will prevent white from
castling it's that doesn't really do
anything for blacks so Queen to c7 it's
a line Maxime usually plays he played it
several times he played against Peter
Svidler in the Greinke just classic he
played it against Wesley so in Norway
chess and also in Abidjan in Cody war
blitz tournament but he never actually
scored a point with it he drew two games
and he lost one game to Wesley so but
okay with efore continuing in this line
with east six and now in all of those
games that we mentioned against wheeler
and against Wesley so Bishop to e3 was
played but here our job was for Bishop
to d3 it's a new move and well it has
never been played before or as we
usually say it is as of this move we
have a completely new game
so after this Bishop to d3 we have
Bush of the e7 Maxime prepares the
castle quinta e to
developing and now Bishop to d7 this
Bishop is now coming to c6 to go over to
this diagonal with castles better job of
castles by Maxine and now II five
freeing this Bishop not allowing black
to push he five himself which would will
severely crippled the influence of this
bishop who whereas now by having this
diagonal open it's really a powerful
piece the strip the c6 by black and now
Knight to g5 already with a threat of
just capturing on aged seven and if
black doesn't really do anything about
it black can give up the dark square
bishop but giving up your Bishop pair
too early in the game isn't something
that well most players would recommend
and if black does nothing just prevents
it then also you can start with f4 and
improving your position so here of
course h6 pushing the knight back and
here a Rajah both took some time and he
found a very nice idea it's just a small
improvement in the position which turns
out to be a huge improvement in the
position he plays Bishop to h7 check
seemingly are useless move but not
really with King back to h8 and now
retreating with the bishop but not the
d3 but rather to c2 which leaves the d3
square open for the white queen with the
threat of course a queen to h7 checkmate
and you cannot capture the night if you
capture the night you get Queen to h5
with chair King goes here and then Queen
to h7 is checkmate on the other hand
after Bishop to see - you could go
Bishop captures on g5 then comes the
bushel captors and g5 you still can't
capture due to the same mating idea but
then you could go nice to d7 and this is
this is possible from black for example
Queen d3 you threaten mate now black has
f5 to defend and now if he captures on
f5 now you play Knight chapters on f6
defending the h7 square with the night
and if Bishop captures G captures and
again now the Queen defends the h7
square but it's a it's a very tricky
line and it opens up the black position
a bit too much so here maxime finds c4
simply not allowing this Queen to d3
move and of course if you capture the
pawn then you lose the night there is no
Queen to h5 check
so here again our job of took some time
and he played rooked
II won it's the strongest movie in the
position and it's a really hard move to
find defending that a five point so the
saw the White Queen can move and he
finds a very nice continuation with
Queen to d8 going after the night on g5
and now Knight to h3 also the queen is
preparing Queen to d5 to go after Queen
to G to checkmate
but it's not a problem or a job of has
everything prepared we have Queen to d5
threatening mate and g2 and now comes
the Knight to f4
pushing the Queen back and guarding the
G to pawn we have Queen to c5 by maksim
and now as well d4 square is covered by
the bishop the D 3 square is covered by
the pawn and you really want to threaten
mate here Bishop to be one now making
room for the Queen and c2 to go after
Queen to h7 we have Bishop to g5 now
threatening the knight an f4 and now
comes well now you you you wouldn't
really gain all that much room by going
Queen to c2 right away black and easily
defend just go g6 but what you can do is
display b4 it's the strongest move in
the position but it's an extremely hard
move to find a reserve of did not play
before he played a much more interesting
move here if you move the Queen it's a
wife will just pick up the c4 pawn and
then he's free to roam around with the
Queen threat and all sorts of stuff
point is if you capture on b3 then first
you play Queen to d3 with the threat of
mate and once g6 is played preventing
checkmate then you go ake a capture son
b3 and now White's position is just
excellent there's already a threat of a
bishop to a3 just straight out winning
material and well there are also sorts
of sacrifices possible maybe Knight
captures and g6 is possible maybe Knight
captures and e6 is possible it would
just be an overwhelming position for
white but Roger doesn't wait he goes for
Knight captures on e6 right away
so the Queen is under attack the rook is
under attack if you don't capture it you
can just resign so you could try Queen
d5 but it doesn't work Queen d5 is
interesting attacking the knight and
also threatening checkmate seemed seems
like you you it's it's free night but
it's not due to f4 now the Queen
prevents mate and also the bishop here
is under attack and if you move the
then you get night c7 again the GT
ponies protected the Queen is under
attack this rock is now under attack and
white will just be much better
so here Maxine doesn't really cut away
it all that much he just captures the
knight and now we have a bunch of
captors and g5 again you cannot capture
the two well a similar mating idea for
example captures check King g8 and now
this important Bishop h7 check you can't
run away the Queen covers f7 and then is
just English 8th verse of g6 check in
here and now when the bishop covers the
square Queen the Queen delivers mate so
after this Queen Bishop g5 we have Queen
to d5 offering well not offering
threatening checkmate
you don't really offer a checkmate and
here Timur had to choose the sword tamer
tamer had to choose whether to go Queen
to g4 or f4 both moves the defend
checkmate and g2 and well what what are
you gonna play here f4 is interesting
but after f4 we would probably see this
end game which well it is better for why
for example Queen captures Queen
captures Bishop captures King captures
and now Bishop that well not right away
but first Bishop to e7 just going after
the rook and only after the rook moves
you would force the rook to capture the
bishop away from the f4 pawn now King
captures rook captures and better to g6
we would have this endgame where the
material on the board is equal but white
is better
timur doesn't like this he goes Queen to
g4 instead now he white could Maxine
could go for the for the same trade here
for example captures we would see
captures captures now Bishop to e7 once
again Luke f7 captures rook captures and
Bishop to g6 difference being this pawn
it is now on f2 instead of an f4 but now
it's actually Maxine who doesn't like
this it's Maxime who prefers the Queen's
on the board he he likes his pressure as
well so Knight to d7 now threatening
Knight characters and on e5 which would
win a pawn but Timur is not easily
scared away he goes Bishop the e4
attacks the black Queen and allows
Knight captures on e5 Maxime captures it
and now Timur has to choose whether he
wants to go Queen h3 Queen to g3 or
Queen to h5 all three moves are
interesting and now it's again maxime to
move his queen is under attack what do
you do here here black has two good
moves Maxime played one of them he
played Quinta b5 he got to the Queen
away from well the threat of the bishop
but there was also an interesting line a
nice to f3 check which opens up the
attack towards the bishop on g5 for
example Bishop captures now you trade
Queens captures captures and after H
captors and g5 we would see Bishop
captures on c6 b captures and now rook
captures on e6 it's really bad and game
for Maxime Raja would be up upon or but
most likely very quickly you would lose
these I will double to pawn CC points so
Maxime avoids the trade with Quint b5
and the now comes Bishop captures and h6
this was always a lurking around but
there was never never time to do it so
of course you cannot capture it you're
getting checkmated you have to do
something else so here we have Bishop
captures on e4 eliminating a very strong
attacker so most of the Maximus pieces
are on darks are on light squares so the
only piece on dark square that is
available to is this night so why not
pick it up Bishop f4 opening up our
discovery from the Queen with King to g8
and now Queen captures on e5 again
offering to transfer the game into the
endgame but Maxime again declines it
with Bishop to d5 now it's a game of
opposite colored bishops and
Maxime likes his chances as usual in a
game of opposites called bishops and the
the side attacking it's like that side
is up a piece since the other bishop is
unable to oppose the other colored
bishop and also there's the threat of
Queen captures on b2 which are job of
defense with rook to e 2 and here the
time situation on the clocks Maxine had
40 minutes and the reserve of had some
16 minutes so a job of definitely better
but time is ticking away we look to f5
by maksim kicking away a job of screen
quinta III and now Queen ta this queen
is now coming either to g6 or
H 5 and then Maxime wants to bring the
other look over to f/8 to really put
pressure on another job of skiing side
now with f3 blocking this bishop and
also if you know if the position allows
it for example if Queen comes over here
you could maybe play g4 not right away
since the Queen can always move back to
g6 and pin pin the Jeep on but it is it
is a very useful move but mostly to
prevent this Bishop from eyeing the G to
pawn and here we have Queen to g6 now
getting the Queen inter game preparing
rook a to f8 and here everyone was
expecting Bishop to g3 it's it's a very
natural move it prevents any threats
along the G file the the DF pawn is
better protected for example if this
sacrifice occurs better captures an f3
then even the Jeep on can capture as the
bishop is blocking it but tamer found in
an even more interesting move h4 he
wants to create a barrier along the G
file with Bishop to g5 so grabbing even
more space but okay rook 8 f8 going
after the best Bishop to g5 now are just
defending there and now a six now Maxime
is out of well active moves he just has
to wait and see what her job will do now
rook 8 d1 finally bringing this rock
into the game and then now we're going
to see a very nice rock lift or maybe
even two with rook the d4 followed by
rook to g4 and here as Maxime knows this
rock is now coming to g4 he well he
retreats with the Queen right away we
have Quinta eh if you leave the Queen
there and you allowed the rook to come
to g4 then some very nasty threats like
well like a Bishop to h6 could be an
option so Queen back to ei eight and now
rook to d4
there is nothing wrong with this black
it doesn't really have any active moves
and then now Queen to c6 again putting
some pressure on the Kings side still
keeping an option of maybe sacrificing
this Bishop on f3 we've looked the g4 as
planned
and now Maxime there was the option here
or going a five it is possible and then
go efore at a try and bust open reserve
of King side a bit but
we should also show what happens if the
bunch of characters on f3 right away it
seems very interesting because after G
captures and rook captures you are now
threatening after the Queen moves a rook
to f1 check and if this Queen can come
to h1 it's just it's gonna be excellent
for black the problem is White has a
better Queen captures on e6 with check
which forces a queen trait and then you
are just down down a piece and you don't
have a good continuation look at when
checking h2 rook F to check route blocks
you survive everything and you're just
up a piece so here maxime decided he's
gonna wait with King to h7 this now
allows the line we've shown as Queen
captures and e6 will no longer come with
check but now our job of just prevents
it Bishop to f4 and it's an excellent
move now it shuts down both of the rooks
along the F file so now
sorry-sorry not that any better clap
source on f3 action is no longer
possible and here the situation on the
clock is 5 minutes for a job of and 25
minutes 25 minutes for maxime and it's
move 35 they still have to make 5 more
moves to reach time control we have rook
a to the f7 by maksim defending that g7
pawn as it's bound to become a target
with something like Bishop to e5 Queen
to d4 and going after the g7 pawn so
Bishop to e5 now the threat well the the
threat is no longer here but you will
either play Queen to d4 to enforce the
attack along this diagonal or or you're
gonna go Queen to F 2 followed by Queen
to g3 and then put pressure on the g7
pawn will be 5 by maksim expanding on
the Queen side but it's again a waiting
move there is no active way to play this
position with black and there now Queen
to f2 a job of prefers this idea with
Queen to g3
a rather than Queen to d4 both ideas
come with a triple attack towards the g7
pawn
the point is if you play Queen to F 2
and G 3 you will also have better
support when you decide to advance your
h1 and also you you keep an eye on your
King side if Queen leaves then maybe
maybe some more ideas are possible and
the reserve of is a very long time
Queen to d7 preparing to defend the g7
pawn now comes rook Queen to g3 and here
rook to h5 just waiting to see to see
what her job of does and here at a job
with two minutes on the clock
he plays Bishop back to d4 now he makes
room for the rook to come to e5 with
Queen back to c7 now offering the Queen
trade a her job of now really has to
decide what to do and he plays rook the
e5 and with when he played roof to e5 he
had three seconds on the clock and with
rook 35 he reaches time control he gains
an additional 30 minutes so here he can
finally relax in a better position which
is which is huge with rook hdf5
bringing the roof back and now Roger
both could decide to put a start pushing
the H pawn but he decides for rook to g5
first and here there are so many threats
for example if you capture them maybe if
at this point recaptures then the bishop
becomes weak if you capture and the rook
captures then the bishop and Queen I'm
the g7 pawn could become a very
dangerous tactic so here
maxime is a whitout again without a move
he plays King to g8 he just waits and
now our job of starts with pushing of
the H bond with h5 h6 is coming so
Maxine has to play something he decides
to trade a pair of rooks here we have
rook captures and g5 Queen captures and
g5 and now Queen to e7 again offering
the Queen trade but Rajaram just
declines he plays Queen to g4 again h6
still remains as a threat and it's very
hard to find to find a useful idea here
so here
Maxine played rope to f5 here for the a
trader Brooks but it doesn't work for
very for a very specific reason which
I'm sure you all see just in case feel
free to pause the video and try to find
the absolute best winning move for tamer
in this position while I give you a
couple of seconds for those who were
able to do it and I'm sure everyone was
able to do it so congratulations to
everyone we're not gonna even mention
those that you just enjoy the show
the move of course is Queen captures an
f5 it's it's just there maxime couldn't
hold on it was too much pressure and he
he just decided to go with the easy way
out so of course it was in this position
that Maxine was Cheryl a gruff resigned
the game as there is nothing more to do
you just lost a very valuable rook and
if you capture it then rook captures on
e7 and you are just in an ending where
you're up a whole rook completely
winning there is no point in in playing
this out so now after Queen captures on
a five maxim reside I resigned and with
this well
his chances of going into the candidates
are you know very very very very low as
as I'm as I understand he can either
qualify through ratings maybe because
even if for example this is how it works
if Dean beats if sorry if Dean bit beats
you Angie in the semi-finals then Bing
is qualified by you know achieving top
two places in the World Cup and he
doesn't have to qualify by ratings then
someone else can qualify by ratings so
it will either be most likely giri but
maybe even maxine for Sheila grub it's a
I don't think anyone calculated it yet
because it's not who is a high rated now
be it's the average across the previous
12 months so that's how you qualify a
through rating to the candidates
tournament but most likely as I
understand it will be Geary but there is
one more way for Maxime to qualify even
if not through ratings and not by
qualifying qualifying through the World
Cup is by waiting for Dean to finish his
game with you Angie and then play for
the third place either against ding
which will be I mean against ding or
against young it will be extremely hard
but if you win third place in the FA the
World Cup you don't qualify to the
candidates but you are sort of
considered more as a wild-card for for
the candidates that's at this moment I
believe that is the best Maxine has so
Tim Tim or job of the first one to
qualify for the candidates tournament
2020 through the video World Cup very
exciting as the last time he played
there was in 2013 in the same
can this tournament that magnus carlsen
one but he also played in Kansas
tournament in 2012 so this will be his
third candidates tournament and with
this win over Maxine holograph Tim
rajabu joins the world top 10 rating
wise so very exciting times for for
chest and Forte more agile who was sort
of dormant for for the past five or six
years but yeah that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it
now for those of you who were waiting
for ding versus young Yi both of the
games both of the classical games ended
in a draw and I really didn't feel like
showing them they were just really
really boring draws I have to put it
that way because they were I mean of
course not for those who play it but III
just don't think it would be exciting
for you guys to watch those games but
you're welcome to check him out on your
own just you know go through the moves
there were very short draws but yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank George Devore Reza
SAR Kumari once upon a gambit Barry
McMurray doc and Luna Escobar who says
that she loves
Rasmus Mortensen really a lot so thank
you a lot for it contributed to my
channel I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos your thinkin for watching and I
will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Phaedo
World Cup checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and and and so on so thank
you I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day